[Applause]
[Music]
do you feel that it feels like all the
ìiî leaks and rumors are about to start
rolling in but before we learn all about
all the games coming out in the future
let's talk about some of the hottest
games launching this month May is full
of monkeys zombies and androids perhaps
the most anticipated game this month is
one you might have already played Dark
Souls remastered is taking us back to
Lordran with a bunch of gameplay and
resolution improvements with some sweet
4k and 60fps support if you're rocking a
ps4 pro Xbox one ex or capable PC we've
got some of that high performance
gameplay on GameSpot right now if you
want to check it out if you missed the
artorias of the abyss dlc back when that
launched don't worry that's included and
if you never play Dark Souls at all
here's your chance to play a remastered
version on ps4 Xbox one or PC on Friday
May 25th
sadly the Nintendo switch version has
been delayed to this summer but that's
ok because the switch is getting a
souped-up re-release of its own much
earlier in May with Donkey Kong Country
tropical freeze you can revisit the
adventure with Donkey Kong and team up
with Diddy Dixie or cranky or flip over
to funky mode to play as one of the
coolest Kong's he can land on dangerous
surfaces with his surfboard and roll
infinitely which is perfect for players
looking for an easier time you can jam
out to the game's great tropical
soundtrack on Friday May 4th until then
let's sit back and remember one of the
best Donkey Kong tunes ever
[Music]
if you're looking for something much
more hardcore you'll find it with
pillars of eternity two dead fire this
RPG sequel cease your cruise sailing the
dead fire archipelago and yes that does
mean you'll be engaging and ship-to-ship
combat it's also a much bigger adventure
than the original all around which means
tons of islands to explore and quests to
complete you can create your own custom
hero and start your adventure on PC on
Tuesday May 8 and now for the zombies
state of decay - is throwing you back
into the open world of undead survival
and for the first time you can take it
on with friends and co-op together or
alone you can step into the shoes of a
survivor and build up your community you
can level up your team RPG style build
up your base with resources and venture
out into the world to find and help
other survivors that's all happening on
Xbox one and PC on Tuesday May 22nd or
four days earlier if you preorder the
ultimate edition state of decay - also
launches day and date on xbox game pass
let's finish up by moving from zombies
to androids Detroit become human comes
from developer Quantic Dream and
director David cage whose signature
style involves making a bunch of choices
that totally change the outcome of each
scene in Detroit those scenes involve
androids finding sentience and coming to
grips with what that means in a world
full of good and not-so-good people you
can find out for yourself exclusively on
ps4 on Friday May 25th and those are
some of the hottest games we'll be
playing all month long as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching guys and I'll
be back with a more focused episode of
new releases next Sunday